first of all i
got notice of this
from the speaker's office only when i
saw the email but i had been it had been
raised with me and i went to make a
point of order in the house of commons
to ask what was going on
and the speaker's statement is pretty
self-explanatory has already been read
out but uh behind it my whole series of
concerns for people like me i've been
sanctioned by the
by the chinese government so you know
should i go to a country that is a good
extradition treaty it's every chance
they'll do what's called a red notice on
me and others so you know they've
interfered already in parliament that to
hear
as we did that there's been an
individual that's clearly paid for
by it sounds like from the chinese state
as an agent of the state has been in
parliament for some considerable time
even up until this morning
and that they're now kicked out of
parliament
passes revoked but i want to know from
the government what in heaven's name are
they doing after all i understand that
this woman arranged money in donations
to the labour party that she met david
cameron that she was given an award now
it turns out from
the prime minister at the time theresa
may i mean this got around and it's
beginning to unravel and the money that
i was just hearing now on your report
just left me breathless so i really need
to know more and i think we have a right
to know more what is going on here and
if this person has been involved in
spying and their son or whatever
involved in what i think is clearly a
form of spying then why are they still
in the country you know i hear that
they're not going to be kicked out well
i have to say that's
wrong i mean if they're agents of one
foreign state and particularly a
disgustingly violent nasty organization
like the chinese communist party that is
guilty of genocide and abuse why in
heaven's name is such an agent allowed
in the country so these are big
questions that we want the government to
answer and the house of commons needs to
make it very clear what they're going to
do about future security the labour mp
uh barry gardner
who
employed um ms lee's son has spoken out
today he told sky news that he's been
liaising with our security services for
many years about mislea and for me that
is the sentence that stuck out the most
from what he told sky news in terms of
why was he liaising about security
services with ms lee why was money still
being accepted what do you want to know
from barry garner about his involvement
with the lee family
well i think that we need to open up
we will only really understand where
it's gone wrong and what we do about it
if this becomes very clear and public if
mi5 have intervened to make sure an
individual now or up until this morning
in parliament has to leave because of
the security uh concerns that they've
raised that's a very serious issue and
if if it is the case that barry gardner
know very well has been
involved with them then i'd like to know
more about what's going on i think we in
parliament now and particularly people
like i'm not it's not a self-pleading
for myself but a number of us have been
sanctioned by the chinese government and
you know we've been working with uh
people trying to flee hong kong from
this abusive regime and the terrible
arrests that have been taking place with
democracy campaigners and i'm now
concerned that our offices may well have
been targeted because we have
information about who some of these
people are you know i'm a member of the
thing called inter-parliamentary
alliance on china and you know we do a
lot of work to try to help those who are
you know for freedom and democracy and
freedom of speech and i i don't want us
to be this source of information about
them that goes back to the chinese
government for them to be arrested or
their families to be abused this is a
serious serious issue and has massive
repercussions so i think we absolutely
have to come clean the government has
got to come to the dispatch box we've
got to make a statement i'd like to see
it today but you know sometimes
thursday's not a great day but i do want
it now and i think we really need to
know yeah ms lee hasn't been arrested
but we honestly remains under
investigation by security services and
as you said the first you heard about
this was the email that went out from
the speaker of the house to um mps and
it came from the interference alert
issued by mi5 that said ms lee had been
engaged in political interference
activities on behalf of the chinese
communist party engaging with members
here at parliament and associated
political entities for those watching
who may not be familiar uh with
china's tactics and what kind of
information they'd be trying to get from
the british government
what are the vulnerabilities here for
the british government what kind of
information
would china be trying to get
well here's one for example i'm a privy
councillor many of the public may not
understand what that is but it does mean
occasionally i will get briefings from
the government on with security
information information about government
activity which is not in the public
domain as a privy councillor that's
called privy council briefings so uh
there are many people in parliament in
that situation so that immediately makes
parliament a very good target because
that sort of information does come into
parliament earlier than it goes into the
public domain there are other areas too
lots of work that parliamentarians are
doing like i mentioned to do with
helping people in foreign climbs it's
also it seems to me that the purpose was
to persuade
subvert parliamentarians i mean you were
talking earlier on in your program about
the amounts of money that have been
transferred into parliament from this
organization and as mi5 have made clear
and parliament has made clear now
through very dodgy setups
to mask where their money was coming
from this is all part of the subversion
process so the chinese government and by
the way we need to remind ourselves this
is a an awful government you know it's
arresting people in hong kong for
nothing more than peaceful protest for
democracy it's guilty we believe and as
jeffrey nice's tribunal has come out and
said they're guilty of genocide of the
of the uyghur people in xinjiang you
know four sterilizations uh re-education
counts for children slave labor uh all
of these things uh in tibet as well and
christians and all the others and
threatening taiwan this is a very
dangerous regime and if they're now
infiltrating parliament and government
it could easily be through parliament
then this is serious serious stuff